certes vous aimez bien jean-michel ou
pas oui bien sûr sophie davant est avec
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la manière des séries c'est pas la
patronne sophie pour moi c'est la
taulière dans la télé sans arrêt c'est
la patronne ya michel drucker et son pic
d'avant moi j'ai beaucoup d'amis et de
fans oui qu'ils sont fous de sophie ils
sont voilà qui son délire sur sophie
quoi ils ont vite ils sont vides à pécho
sur un bail quoi je suis moitié anglais
présentent jamais ses joies on va
s'occuper de toi tu va repartir de ce
projet de poules avec la veste à mon
avis sera pas possible tu vas devoir me
dire quel objet tués dans en train de
tripoter tu mettras t'es d'min des deux
côtés comme ça que tu penses mais c'est
jean michel salesse alex ce qui bat gens
sachent c'est quelqu'un de est ce qu'on
peut lui mettre autour actions aig
on peut les mettre leur tour un sophiste
yoplait le retour assez pierre-jean
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
démission ya maintenant quelques
dizaines de mois dans une case qui était
à 5 %
voilà aujourd'hui maintenant elle est
vraie elle a fait 4 fois le sport de
cette caste absolument extraordinaire
inertie à 404 première génération
minitel effectivement vous en attendez
entre 5000 et 10000 euros non non c'est
non je pense alors que jamais de leur
régime bien ce côté gentleman farmer
c'est là le pantalon en velours côtelé
non là bas il a juste merci d'hackney je
trouve ça sympa c'est moi qu'il a
répondu c'est moi qui paye donc ça
d'habitude on discute on discute serein
pour l'avenir et bon moi j'ai déplacé on
espère qu'ils se verront le jour
merci sophy sava sophie et me regarde et
vous direz vous voyez un ouf
mais vous êtes une romantique ça vous
surprendront pas du tout alarmés c'est
vrai souk chine et romantique quoi donc
il est romantique ses meilleurs vous
vous êtes le matin que la batterie batik
ceci vous aimez bien jean-michel ou pas
oui bien sûr
j'aime bien le côté poivre et sel et les
barbus de trois jours oui et méfiez vous
quand même
il est pas mal non ça dépend pour quoi
en fait c'est à dire oui de nuit
bertreau pour une vie jean michel horn
allons peut-être pas jusque là mais on
peut réfléchir aux activités très
méchant qu'elle allait bien jean-michel
un sofitel demandé s'offrir est-ce que
vous accepteriez un dîner avec jean
michel maire vous allez revenir à ce
qu'elle n'avait pas fait la dernière
fois c'est pour moi c'est cadeau c'est
moi qui régale
sa demande a choisi un du hip hop aux
tables
[Rires]
[Musique]